after World War two with most of Europe
and ruins tensions grew between the
Soviet Union and the United States it
was clear that the next global
superpower required the ability to both
launch and successfully defend nuclear
attacks from intercontinental ballistic
missiles the United States most
vulnerable point of attack was over the
North Pole
so in 1958 a joint effort between the
United States and Canada was established
NORAD the North American Aerospace
Defense Command an important line of
defense was the semi-automatic ground
environment it was an automated system
of over a hundred long-distance radar
scattered across North America they were
connected to computerized radar systems
that transmitted tracking data using
telephone lines or radio waves all this
information was fed into the primary
Warning Center very deep inside Cheyenne
Mountain in Colorado this application of
machine-to-machine communication allowed
operators to make split-second decisions
using the information transmitted and
processed automatically by computers
this idea of being online was quickly
adapted and advanced by universities in
the following years as they understood
the potential of computer networking the
thing that makes the computer
communication network special is that
inputs the workers that be the team
members who are geographically
distributed in touch not only with one
another but with the information base
with which they work all the time and
this is obviously going to make a
tremendous difference in how we plan
organize and execute almost everything
of any intellectual consequence if we
get into mode in which everything is
handled electronically and your only
identification is a little plastic thing
you stick into the machinery but I can
imagine that they want to get that
settled up with your bank account just
right now and put it through all the
checks and that would require a network
money transfers were just one of a
growing number of applications which
require encryption to remain secure as
the internet grew to encompass millions
around the world a new problem emerged
at the time encryption required two
parties to first share a secret random
number known as a key how could two
people who have never met agree on a key
without letting Eve who is always
listening also obtained a copy in 1976
Whitfield Diffie and Martin Hellman
devised an amazing trick to do this
first let's explore how this trick is
done using colors how could Alice and
Bob agree on a secret color without
efiling it out the trick is based on two
facts
once it's easy to mix two colors
together to make a third color
and to give in a mix color it's hard to
reverse it in order to find the exact
original colors this is the basis for a
lock easy in one direction hard in the
reverse direction this is known as a
one-way function now the solution works
as follows first they agree publicly on
a starting color let's say yellow next
Alice and Bob both randomly select
private colors and mix them into public
yellow in order to disguise their
private color now Alice keeps your
private color and sends her mixture to
Bob
and Bob keeps his private color and
sends his mixture to Alice now the heart
of the trick Alice and Bob add their
private colors to the other person's
mixture and arrive at a shared secret
color
notice how Eve is unable to determine
this color since she needs one of the
private colors to do so and that's the
trick now to do this with numbers we
need a numerical procedure which is easy
in one direction and hard in the other
this brings us to modular arithmetic
which is also known as clock arithmetic
for example to find 46 mod 12 we take a
rope of length 46 units
and wrap it around a clock of 12 units
which is called the modulus and where
the roll bends is the solution so we say
46 mod 12 is congruent to 10 easy now to
make this work we need a prime modulus
such as 17 instead of 12 then we find a
primitive root of 17 in this case 3
which has this important property that
when raised to different exponents the
solution distributes uniformly around
the clock 3 is known as the generator so
if we raise 3 to any exponent X the
solution is equally likely to be any
integer between 0 and 17 now the reverse
procedure is hard given 12 find the
exponent 3 needs to be raised 2 this is
called the discrete logarithm problem
and now we have our one wave function
easy to perform but hard to reverse
given 12 we would have to resort to
trial and error to find the matching
exponent how hard is this with small
numbers it's easy but if we use a prime
modulus which is hundreds of digits long
it gets seriously hard even if you had
access to all computational power on
earth it could take thousands of years
to go through all possibilities so the
strength of a one-way function is based
on time needed to reverse it now this is
our solution first Alice and Bob agree
publicly on a prime modulus and a
generator in this case 3 and 17 then
Alice selects a private random number
say 15 and calculates 3 to the power of
15 mod 17 and sends the result publicly
to Bob then Bob selects his private
random number 13
and calculates 3 ^ 13 mod 17 and sends
the result publicly to Alice and now the
heart of the trick Alice takes Bob's
public result and raises it to the power
of her private number to obtain the
shared secret which in this case is 10
Bob takes Alice's public result and
raises it to the power of his private
number resulting in the same shared
secret now notice they did the same
calculation though it may not look like
it at first first look at Alice the 12
she received from Bob was calculated as
3 to the power 13 mod 17 so her
calculation was the same as 3 to the
power of 13 to the power of 15 mod 17
now look at Bob the 6 he received from
Alice was calculated as 3 to the power
of 15 mod 17 so his calculation was the
same as 3 to the power of 15 to the
power of 13 mod 17 notice they did the
same calculation with the exponents in a
different order they both end up with 3
raised to the power of their private
numbers without one of these private
numbers 15 or 13 Eve will not be able to
find the solution this is how it's done
while Eve is stuck grinding away at the
discrete logarithm problem and with
large enough numbers we can say it's
practically impossible for her to break
the encryption
[Music]